Even though the spotlight has disappeared, the way that three
[INAUDIBLE]
shadow system works in this case is that it dims down all kinds of contribution
including ambient. The reason the spotlight itself disappears is that the
Lambert material is normally evaluated per vertex for illumination. The ground
plane has just four corners all of which are outside the spotlight's area of
influence. So, just the ambient light is applied. The shadow in the scene isn't
baked on. It's in fact evaluated per pixel. But that's a separate part of the
illumination process in this case. A spotlight is not a specular highlight, it
effects diffuse and shiny objects, alike. Finally, you can think of the area
outside of a spotlight as being in shadow. But that doesn't explain why the
Lambert material effects it. If you use the Lambert material and were to test
like the ground plane into a grid of squares, you'd start to see the effect of
the spotlight as you can see in these images. Going from left to right, the
ground plane is
[INAUDIBLE]
more and more, catching the spotlights effect better and better. However,
evaluating the spotlights effect per pixel instead of per vertex, means many
fewer triangles needed to be generated and processed.